chair we're now live on youtube
thank you chris good morning everybody
and please put your microphones on mute
when you're not speaking
and use your electronic hand or wave
your hand
when you want to speak
could we do a roll call
councillor bill event
yep councillor connet
councillor evans yes i'm here councillor
nuttel
president councillor pete president
and councillor linda federick present
thank you bear any apologies
no apologies today chair thank you
to approve and sign the minutes of the
meetings held on the 2nd of october and
the
9th of november 2020
if we go first to the minutes of 2nd of
october
has anybody got any matters arising from
these minutes
can i propose these minutes through the
chair have i got seconder
thank you and
carry on to the minutes of
chairs sorry um can i just check if
there's an agreement
yes please vote on that
council of relevant four
councillor connect before
councillor evans four councillor nettle
four councillor piet paul
and councillor linda pedreck four
unanimous chair
thank you and moving to the minutes of
the 9th of november
2020 any matters arising from these
chairman yes i may um with regards to
the minutes in relation to
uh 25 the reference to the um
finding of facts it says in resolve
finding effects
decision notice um as we know council
eden
has written for the council concerned
that the decision notice
um does not reflect
the findings of the investigator may i
just have a view from the monitoring
officer of a deputy monitoring
officer um that that the minutes as
they are set out are correct
um is there anything that members need
to be aware of
um i just sent me some guidance because
i know we're being asked to approve the
minutes and i know
obviously there is a particular interest
in in the way things appear to be worded
thank you councillor connect monitoring
officer
um um madam i obviously can't answer
that because i wasn't at the meeting the
the members of the committee are the
ones to obviously confirm the accuracy
of the
minutes i understand the decision letter
reflects the discussions obviously
in part two so again it's only the
committee you can actually um confirm
that
thank you thank you for that
um thank you chairman i i did appreciate
that the monitor
officer wasn't at the meeting but the
deputy monitoring officer was
and maybe it would be appropriate just
to hear from the deputy because
he was obviously there for the duration
of the meeting i think
it might be useful just to have that
clarity that i'm seeking thank you thank
you councillor collette
um deputy monitoring officer
thank you chair um i i
i appreciate where counselor con is
coming from i
we've heard what the monitoring officer
has said and there's little much
that i could add to that i as
everybody's aware this meeting i was the
person in the chair at the time um
there i have no reason to to believe
that those
minutes are not an accurate reflection
but that's on the back of
what you've already heard from the
monitoring officer
sorry sorry
round paul sorry um what i was going to
say sorry chair was that
which which would be my position in any
event
thank you councillor connie
oh well i'm grateful to the deputy
monitor officer who was at that meeting
on the night
but for his guidance chairman obviously
um you know
um an issue has been raised and i
thought before the
members of this committee consider
whether they wish to approve the minutes
it might be just useful to take a moment
to have some guidance on that and i'm
grateful to the deputy monitoring
officer for his
his view thank you thank you for that
so through the chair shall i propose
that we accept these minutes
can i have a second up catch the
boulevard
yeah sorry before we go to the vote i
notice in the minutes it says that copy
of the decision notice is attached
to the minutes i can't see that decision
notice attached to the um or the copy of
the letter i should say attached to the
minutes
should it copy the letter being attached
a minute
i think because it's already on the
website um
and we'd already approved it and that
that's probably why there's no copy of
the minutes
of the decision notice attached so we
can make sure that
a copy gets attached to these minutes
thank you
that will be helpful thank you okay
thank you in that case i'll second the
minutes thank you councillor boulevant
shall we go to the vote
councillor bill event
four councillor connett paul
councillor evans paul councillor nuttall
yes four cancer piets paul
and council linda pedrec oh that's
unanimous chair
thank you um the
item number four the new lga model code
of conduct
and i've read read it through
first of all to the monitoring officer
are there any
changes that we need to
are there any substantial changes that
we need to note
no i mean that's the the local
government association's model code
all four group leaders were asked for
their comments prior to
christmas i've had nothing back from
newton says no group
or the independent group obviously the
conservative and the liberal democrat
leaders are here today so they can give
your comments
um and that's physician madam there's
not material changes actually between
the o
code and the new code same sort of
issues arise
respect declaring interest not
participating when you have an interest
not using um the council to obviously
promote your own personal
interests respect the all matters
consistent with our current code
and it's hard to see why you wouldn't
adopt the new code madam
thank you do any counsellors want to
speak to this
catch the bill of aunt yeah i'm i
i think adopting this set of uh in
codes is absolutely the right thing for
us to do
my major concern is obviously the
i call it the abuse of the system that
we've seen over the last two years
and do we have within this adequate
means of addressing what has become
completely unacceptable abuse by certain
councillors
towards officers and other councils
alike
that's the only concern that's the only
real concern that i have
thank you councilor billy monitoring
officer do you want to
pass comment um i mean clearly
um adopting a code in itself this would
be a recommendation by the way to full
council
clearly adopting a new code is not going
to in itself improve or promote or
maintain high standards of conduct
the lack of sanctions to effectively
suspend members doesn't help but the
government's still looking at that
and as i say it's hard to see why you
wouldn't want to
follow the national line or recommended
line from the local government
association by adopting or recommending
adoption of this code thank you for that
can i can i just ask a question and you
say the
government are looking at this so this
um increasing the sanctions can't be
looked at by the lga
it has to come from the government is
that right um it would require a change
in the law
and clearly the lga is only promoting a
model code
it's a it's not a requirement legally
for you to adopt it
um and as i say changes in sanctions
would require
a change in legislation there's other
things i think the government are
concentrating on at the moment
thank you any other counselors
want pascal councillor evans
sorry sorry i'm sorry
sorry okay um i've no issues with with
it as it stands and adopting it can i be
very pedantic the the front page local
government association model code of
contact
uh line three can we have behavior
spelled with a u in it so it's not a
an americanization of the word behaviors
thank you councillor evans is that okay
monitoring officer
councillor comet
thank you chairman um the monitoring
officer
uh wrote to all the group leaders i
think it might be
in late december possibly early january
asking them
for the views of their groups uh by the
end of january i recall it was
um obviously interesting to hear what uh
montgomery says about
uh replies uh that haven't been received
but
for the lib dem group i replied uh in
good time within the time scale
and the liberal democrat view was to
adopt the lga code of conduct as
recommended i think it's useful to uh
just recap
uh on why um there are
only if you like light touch sanctions
uh previously when the standards brought
for england
existed it could uh disqualify
councillors
and with that came an appeals process uh
eric pickles when he was secretary of
state
abolish these standards brought for
england and a new lighter touch system
came in
and because the sanctions are relatively
modest there is no right of appeal
chairman um obviously
people are taking a view i know that
there are various
comments from groups that representing
democratic services officers or
monitoring officers and the lga
you know this is as the bonjour says is
in the mix and no doubt government will
review that
at some point in the future uh to my
mind chairman
uh i think it'd be wise for the council
to adopt to the lj model code
and hopefully move forward uh with that
chairman
but we identified earlier and i did
respond to the managing officer
but i'm not sure she clarified that when
she spoke to the committee i may have
missed that thank you
thank you yeah
well i did say when i introduced it with
regards to the consultation i haven't
had any responses back from newton says
no the independent group
in terms of the conservative group my
understanding
from conversations with council
development that they're very supportive
of any recommendations from the local
government association so that's their
feedback as i understand
thank you that's correct thank you
if there's no more questions would
someone like to propose it
counselor bill levant have we got a
second up
council appeared
council appeared thank you councillor
pitt can we take a vote on that then
please
that's the relevant paul councillor
connect
four councillor evans four
councillor nuttel four cancer piet
councillor linda pedreck that's
unanimous chair
thank you just before we go i actually
want to say something which i hope
is appropriate in the in this committee
over the last 12 months i have witnessed
some of our offices
being maligned publicly and their
integrity being challenged
i consider this to be very unfair as the
officers have no right of reply in
public forum
our offices work very hard for members
and this year because the pandemic
it has been even harder and even more
stressful
we as members should be supporting our
officers to enable them to do their jobs
effectively
and i hope that you will all agree with
me on that
thank you so that's the end of the
meeting then
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank you
thank you thank you very much bye